Cinderella I'm your fairy godmother I
was gonna start with I'm your fairy
godmother and then you look like we
usually do but then he said that through
me also I don't know what the hell that
was sounds like Tim Curry from Rocky
Horror Picture Subaru so great now we
have this really awkward opening well
it's your show
bitch Cinderella or Ella as we're now
told was her real name the whole time
don't I feel like an ass I was calling
her Cinderella it turns out that's an
insult it's actually sin dirty Ella sin
dirty Ella and I forgot her meal name so
I feel like a dick but if she's
Cinderella
that's Cinderella ah I'm pronouncing it
wrong well that's just one of the many
changes that happens in the updated
Disney version of the classic fairy tale
probably be putting a lot of things yes
yes um you know the story it's uh
spoiler will say spoiler alert now as if
it freaking man is kind like finding out
the ship sinks in Titanic you know is
there's some stuff you can we will talk
about the movie including its supposed
twists sister so okay so um Elia say you
know the story based on the fairy tale
that Disney helped make even more
popular and sort of almost copyrighted
in its way cuz it's just so insanely
popular um I had no desire to see this
movie originally did you uh know Monday
wifey so we marriage is a wonderful
thing in there right
so um but but here's the thing that we
should probably make very clear cuz I
did gotta get a conversation with us
going to you saw it first
I don't want so yeah what wasn't gonna
do a sibling bribe for you like do you
gotta see this son of a bitch to Al's
like are you thinking mad about
cindarella yeah yeah you just gotta go
see it and I did it I did to I was on it
so and I said there were parts of it
that are also really good on ya so you
just really want to get feedback but
something we both agreed on before we
even start this with pride is good to
know
uh the Disney Cinderella now talking
about the original fairy tale we're
talking about the Disney Cinderella the
anime version well not the best or most
empowering or anything I think we both
kind of feel gets a bit of a bum rap uh
everyone overplayed like there was a
it's the absolute worst and I'm like
really there's net sleeping yes Aurora
and Sleeping Beauty literally she
nothing yeah no she twirls she twirls
that is all she band has no character
she sleeps she has sixteen lines in the
whole movie I think uh and I think it's
fair to say we both like the original
Cinderella but we both acknowledge yeah
yeah it has issues and time differences
and the times of change and stuff but I
think what we really would I really like
about it is that even though you can
make the arguments of you know it's
anti-feminist and stuff like that uh to
me growing up watching it I didn't see
as much why don't you do something why
don't you go do whatever I saw very much
here's a fucking hard worker who's
caught in this place and is kept
ignorant and isolated and sheltered away
yeah and there's really not much she can
do which was specially when I period
yeah which will bring up in cuz this
movie's different and it creates a whole
series of problems yeah so uh you know
and also the fairy tale aspect but you
know what take that up the moral the
moral is stand back do double you'll get
your way bullshit
this woman works her ass off and she is
trying her best to keep this optimistic
point of view and be nice to whoever
there is all there are are fucking rats
so she'll just you know whatever I'll
take what I got they end up helping her
in the end because of her kindness and
because she did work so hard and that's
the
that's the point the weird thing about
the Disney movie is the original
animated film is that it's just as much
about the rats reaction to her like
they're just as much main active players
in the story maybe a little too much
no and I agree that's a problem when
they when their actions have no effect
on the plot when this is like and we're
just gonna have a side cartoon that's
where the movie for me as an adult I'm
just like no but when they take an
active role when they're trying to help
or make the dress when they're trying to
help get her out of the room at the end
in like I think a friend called it
Hitchcockian it's like it's like at the
ending to a Hitchcock movie
the rats stuck in the pocket and trying
to get the key out and then throwing it
up the stairs and then the cat stops it
is very vertigo yeah um it gets really
crazy and so much of their movie there's
this weird like Upstairs Downstairs
dynamic of like if you treat the rats
almost like their fellow servants in the
house cuz that's almost what they're
played off as she basically you've got
the stepmother and the two stepsisters
and the cat that's its own universe and
then there's cinderella
and the rats oh we were just going out
just a brief summary of the movie night
okay here is the class diversify no
right in the cab okay Cinderella and the
rats are in their own caste system and
really the rats are lower than
Cinderella what does she do she doesn't
treat them like crap like the
stepmothers darbian to the cat or
anything no she that's the thing she
saves the wrath she saves like the
civilization of people no she saves like
when you start putting it together she
saves Gus in the beginning and then she
has ready-made clothes for these rats
and I was watching this movie a second
time and I suddenly realized I'm like
wow she must have done this like a
hundred times there's like a hundred
freaking rats here like they have like a
church decade or the Church of sinner I
like you know she's almost from bondage
elements to the problem but she was
building her own fucking willard army of
talking rats
okay we're get really sad by the bottom
by weeping she's doing work yeah no the
point is that what I was getting to with
the moral at least from a guy point of
view
like I said I didn't grow up female
maybe it's something else I don't know
but from a guy point of view I saw very
much and so did Disney because this was
his favorite that if you work hard and
you stay kind and optimistic somebody
will notice and karma will work its way
out and that hard work and that kindness
will pave a way to something really
great it's not a it's not even always
that someone will notice she wants to
get out as well yeah I think we're gonna
have to yeah we'll get to but from now
logically you know does the prince have
any character no no too much focus on
the mice yes is there your fairy
godmother make any sense in this movie
no but she doesn't in any way but the
same the same way I think like Wizard of
Oz works I don't think it operate it's a
fairy tale very much so and I don't
think it operates on lodging I think it
operates on emotion and emotionally I
think that only is the character they're
not the best you know but she's still
someone to get angry if someone goes
across the floor and she lose her temper
and she'll break down when all hope is
gone you know when the dress is ripped
apart and stuff so there is an actual
human being yeah and this one she's just
more ho-hum why and which brings us to
this movie which makes uh which makes
several changes to try and update it and
make it better and smarter more
lysosomes though makes it worse
yes well Kate some things work out well
some of the changes are they have a
little bit more of a conversation with
the prince
thank you the princess nobody in them in
the original Prince actually has a
character yeah oh no an all of those
scenes are let's be on it shamelessly
ripped off from ever after but that's
fine I'm like you know what you need to
do that yeah like have them meet first
they meet on horseback and they're
riding around and their conversations
are generally more interesting and they
have a conversation yeah I think this is
the prince have one line in the original
animated film I think just hmm
yeah so yes so it takes like that said
you know now so that's a good attempt
that's a good at enter there's a tense
at adding a little bit more of like why
she's still stuck there and how you know
sort of the hierarchy of like you know a
prince has to marry a princess not a
servant girl
whatever she is um there's an attempt by
people in the palace at least to say and
at least the stepmother be like yeah lo
this thing this ain't happening what you
think you can marry some D's gonna marry
some peasant girls so they tried really
hard to try and make this I don't want
say more PC but try to make a little bit
more sense out of the morals that Disney
has really been cursed for like you know
demonizing girls with and stuff like
that which hold our conversation but the
whole moral itself is simply be kind
half Kennedy yes well and we'll get to
that in a second too so uh so for me a
lot about half of these changes I think
are clever I think are pretty smart
the other half ironically by trying to
update it and make it more equal and
make it more logical it actually makes
less sense because they're forgetting
it's a fairy tale and when you're trying
to bring in this logic and balance it
out you're noticing all these other
things that don't make sense about it
obviously because it's a fairy tale
and a lot of that comes around the
biggest problem to me which is
Cinderella who is not interesting in
this has little to no character j-
Leela's completely yeah no that's
compelling than in the animated version
where she does have a lot of character
yeah I mean comparison not like yeah
this is the thing whether you like or
dislike uh the animated Cinderella I
understand either like we're not getting
we don't see the arguments against it
but it's that movie has a lot of problem
yeah when I was watching you the second
time there were moments or I'm like
fast-forward like I was just like I
can't deal with these rats anymore wait
even smells not bearing on the plot but
I mean but Cinderella again in the
original is not the most fascinating but
you're still on her side and you feel
her struggle cuz she will get angry she
will get for yours I just don't keep her
cool and you see her trying to keep it
together she's always holding on and
like the glasses now and I say David
torment exhibited upon her is severe
yeah like there III there was this scene
where she got caught doing something in
the the stepmother who is evil incarnate
in the animated version sitting on the
bed petting the cat like a Bond villain
this is like well we can't have that so
let's have you
this and that and wash the drapes and
then do the carpets and like literally
this list goes on and I'm like oh my god
so in this world there are consequences
like she is being kept in line by
literally being told you were going to
do a thousand things for every one thing
you do wrong and there's never a part of
her that's like you know oh okay you
know Tweel IDI whatever she'll what I
think what people confuse is that she's
trying to keep her optimism and her
hopes high while doing the joy but
yesterday another one's like okay like
let's what you'll get through this
you'll get through it like she's trying
to survive when she's working with SIA
hesitations working within the system so
when she breaks when she finally breaks
in that scene that rips every locale
give me your girl boy whatever it's
every kid's heart out when the dress is
ripped apart and she goes we need and we
need to put emphasis on this when the
dress is violently horrific ly torn to
shreds in what is maybe the closest
these thing to like a rape scene or your
guys Disney Val has ever had like an
anime like literally they like rip her
apart and she's just left they're like
oh well it's like violating and like and
then they just saunter off and she's
just left there in stone-cold silence
like dress completely shredded and
you're just like Jesus crooked but that
scene is earned because you see how much
he's putting up with and how much he is
trying to keep optimistic and we do get
a scene we get a scene in this actually
kind of early on and it's not a bad
scene and it's actually done a good
moment when finally the mother and the
stepsisters are not letting her eat with
them and they pretty much say you know
you can't eat without it's saying you
are not family and she goes into the
kitchen she just drops everything and
starts crying and it works that was a
scene where it's like that anyone would
break but the problem with that is
because she has so little emotion and
she is too optimistic too happy-go-lucky
too hopeful which I definitely think was
possible under you know such conditions
but there is never a point where you
feel like she's losing anything or
putting anything on the line so when the
big scene happens where they
only rip the dress is not nearly as bad
uh and she goes out crying and
Steinmeier my wife leaned over to me he
said it was as big a deal as in the
other one I remember feeling so bad and
the other hand some of it is the fact
that it was such a violent scene in the
first movie in the animated film and in
this one it says oh like just is it rips
her sleeve off a bit and a couple others
like grab a ribbon or two and I just
remember talking about this afterwards
I'm like we've established in this movie
that this cinderella supposedly is like
smarter so I was like we've proven in
this Cinderella she can ride a horse cuz
she's hops on a horse early movie goes
to the village has Lawrence in the
knowledge that they claim she doesn't
have it's just you're antisocial to
service no freakin dress it like it
should take twenty minutes yeah horse
enjoy yourself it's a little rare and
another low rib and it's where deer
destroy it is fed she takes like this
she gets a case of the stupid flu and
just is like oh and I'm like you have
all the means woman to do whatever it is
you need to do to get to this fall this
is not like the other one where
literally she is left with a piece of
cloth just tattered around her it's like
oh god yeah and and what makes it even
stranger is she thinks she's going to
see some apprentice at the palace she
doesn't even realize this guy's the
prince
so I'm like so you could have gone in a
dress that you sewed up quickly to see a
freaking apprentice in the another movie
at least I'm like well she's seeing a
prince hmm you know they won't write a
read
yeah they may they won't let her in
looking like that but she just and
here's the thing too is that you I can
already hear what a while you were
thinking right now it's a fuckin fairy
tale come on but this movie really tries
to go out of its way to like I said add
more lot you can add more reason and in
some in some movies and retelling it can
work I think frozen it works very well I
think that was a good balance oh it was
pretty good I know the ever after was
good I mean that feels wonderful that's
the exact opposite silliness is that
it's so postmodern feminist message
crammed in medieval times but bub Noah's
character yeah
counting and it's so much fun and I want
to know where was gonna go yeah well and
you know and you felt the emotions of
these characters because she's
interested characters are interesting
some of the characters in this Richard
the Prince isn't that bad
the King is wonderful um Claudius from
Hamlet yeah I mean he's just always
great um Kate Blanchet has mom she has
marbles no no she has moments but like
here's the thing here's one realizing
with this this movie this retelling has
good starts of ideas like what you see
sort of why the stepmother what why is
she so mean to the Cinderella and stuff
like that you could marry me yeah but
you you see her watch the father and
Cinderella and see like he misses the
mutt be original mother a lot and she
realizes well I'm not going to be the
mother I'm never gonna be true family so
she decides to sort of separate now
that's really smart but then they go too
overboard and they ever do the wicked
laughing haha now Luna Park days two
seconds waiting with said I have you
that scene where you that you said you
liked where she says you're not part of
the family you know maybe better a few
eight somewhere else that scene is
completely ruined because after
Cinderella leaves like I swear to God
Cate Blanchett just is there and she's
like yeah they give her this yeah
because well a de Vil well yeah and I
know what they're trying to do there
again the sort of ties in with trying to
make it more realistic well why would
this you know stepmother who's so rigid
and why would she think her
granddaughter's can be anything and why
would she dress them like this and stuff
cuz she has to have some clay and they
again they show like she's actually a
bit of a party animal and she's into
whatever's sort of new they heard and
really attention to my life of comic
buffoon again that goes against what the
emotion of the story is trying to do and
that's why we just found motherly Anna
me it was pure evil and is still one the
most terrifying villains in the Disney
film ever and you can argue well with
your motivation whether the who cares
she was free like she was scary and that
was the important thing particularly the
kids watching fairy tales like you don't
need them to be comic buffoons and you
don't even need XYZ motivation you just
need to be able to be scared by them and
take them seriously
I couldn't do either with Kate Blanche
and I'm like you're way too goofy to
take seriously and therefore you're not
scary well and I think again when people
are fine when we attack like the logic
of a plot of really any movie we attack
the matrix a lot for this we attack
Christopher Nolan films a lot for this
about them trying to over explain
everything so what it does is I get you
in this mindset okay this is a world of
logic and reason and technicals and
details but if you go too much into that
you're going to miss the most important
part which is making a connect to make
an emotional connection on top of that
you're gonna question all the other
things that you didn't address on that
no movie can address on because you
can't explain everything in a film and
but because you're trying so hard you're
missing the emotional element that's
what I hear
but that's why films like some of the
Disney fairy tales and Cinderella and
Wizard of Oz I argue where the wild
things are as well work because they're
saying we're not gonna do the detail we
are going to do just a little bit detail
but the emotion is what we want to get
you won you will feel for everything
that happens to these characters where
you don't yeah and the problem is every
time they try to fix one problem they
open up three new cans of worms and if
you let's look at what the animated
Disney film gave us too many rats yes
and the prince has no character these
are two problems but if you look at the
logicals I can't figure out what
Cinderella could've or should have done
differently because given the time
they're not even a time period that if
you watch the Disney film closely
there's something I notice you never see
the outside of that house that Chateau
you never see a village you never see a
ride a Horace I'm not convinced she can
ride a horse even you know she rides in
the carriage but there is literally any
time she's out of line she's given
thirteen thousand more chores to do you
have no idea what's out there it could
just be a big giant scary forest out
there the film never shows you and in
some ways I think that works to its
advantage cuz as a child
I just took it on faith that you just
don't want to go out there what the hell
is out there how do you honor are you
gonna go on top of that I brought
for it she got her when she was a child
here she's at very least like yeah maybe
even older she looks seventeen eighteen
yeah I mean so and that's when the
father dies so it's not that long she's
you know almost pretty much a grown-up
you know where with the other one
because she got her so young it kind of
makes sense over the years you were kind
of brain washer and stuff and I do like
again there's some things in here where
they do sort of show the transformation
of going from you know a stepmothers
just asking it sure here there is
setting sort of standards to it just to
gain more and more degrading and it
almost kind of works but again it just
goes too far then into the fairy tale
element uh where it the logic suddenly
doesn't make sense and the two just are
so competing with each other and as you
guys needed this one they show you
what's outside the Chateau they show
that she can ride a horse without a
saddle and control its Mane she can kind
of command the animals she runs a sort
of deer stag and is like go run away
save from the princes hunting party and
more importantly she goes to the village
at least twice for as far as I can tell
is just running errands picking up food
where she encounters former servants
that were in the house who literally
look at her and they're just like why
are you still there
sentimental value she can leave why
would she want my parents wanted me to
watch after the house and I shall watch
after them ya know I think my tail might
get married and go to the palace kisses
someone else can grant know what else I
think your parents would have wanted
well maybe not your dad because he
married a psycho but they probably would
have not wanted you to sit there and get
abused 24/7 and browbeaten and live in
the Attic in a house that the stepmother
the first thing she does in this movie
is transform the inside of it to her
liking so I'm like it's not even your
damn house anymore anyway so there it
was such a bullshit excuse I'm like no
you're an idiot well and that's why it
feels like to me rather than trying to
wherever after try to retell Cinderella
in a stronger brighter light that you
know is not flawless but you know is
more fun and interesting and has
character and has emotion you're
invested and you like the twists and
turns and stuff like that these feel
like they're making excuses for and you
know that you know the faults of the
pants are and say no we're not bad but
you're leaving out what was so good and
the correct original why people like to
hang for it I can't believe this film is
doing critically as good as it is back
that it's making money is no surprise
yes left the words disney and cinderella
on something when I when I went to see
it I saw it opening night there were
literally girls and little Cinderella
dresses showing up I'm like this will
make money but the fact that the critics
just like just fell for it hook line and
sinker I'm like can't you see how this
is just dumb the first 10 minutes of
this might be the most suffering full I
sat through a movie in a long time no
Gretchen I try to avoid bad movies but
this is like oh my god I don't know
maybe a bear bears look like rec room
for a drag I really thought oh my god
I'm not could be able to get through
this like this is you bet and it gets
better thank God so it's just yeah
you're if you're dragged to this movie
and you see the first 10 minutes just
take a breath you'll get better cuz it
is the most sugar-coated bullshit I mean
luckily hinder garden holy
yeah well agent fucking Carter who I
love she was great Captain America she
was great agent Carter terrible in the
first day once general thank you like
all the villains like Holly Amanda be
kind YouTube music we're swell we're so
fucking happy with so fucking happy
Cinderella isn't everything so wonderful
yes papa yeah let's fly a little paper
butterflies every row but do you think I
really talk to animals but well if you
believe I have a kinda yeah poor Helia
oh it's like poor on the first few
minutes like it's like you've died it's
like if a Thomas Kinkade painting became
a movie
oh no and just add in like you know even
more sugar-coated flops poor heylia
while having to deliver lines like of
course I believe you can talk to animals
and of course I believe hey godmothers
existed like I was like oh this poor
woman she's so much better than this and
Lily James who is fine and down Abbi
still playing a flaky character I like
better than us and in this it's just
everything she says it's not like it's
like no instead instead of giving her a
character they're trying to give this
mold for girls to pretend to be uh and
that is offensive to me well that is
what you do with any character boy or
you know I I just hate that especially
when you have a character like I said
it's not great but is at least defined
is she's a define character and this
really has no defined character outsider
we're gonna shove some morals in your
face and when we get to you no morals to
up whatever updated morals are actually
working more against it than for it and
when it got to the scene where they're
at they're at the ball there she is she
has the carriage and she has the the
dress and everything everything looks
wonderful and they really take their
time to have her soak it up and really
enjoy I'll say myself I feel nothing now
for her I wish I did and I'll say myself
what if Anna was here what if Elsa was
here what Belle was here what Tiana was
here I would totally be emotionally
invested
I'll tell ya it's because she did it
yeah she didn't nothing in this film was
earned
she didn't earn in you could argue well
my kitchen you rather do a animated
version well okay hey she tried to make
the dress herself and then they made her
go back to work so the rats did it but
it wasn't even about that it said the
violation of ripping the dress apart was
so horrific that at least you felt when
she was getting the happiness of the
ball that it was somehow earned and in
this there's no emphasis I hate to say
it you need to torture her Mel you do
she you need
mr. Xie feels that she can feel bandaged
I'm happy that is what makes it up like
that's what's mcdhh Raman if your moral
you be kind have kids and I swear to god
I'm not making this up mommy judging
alone yeah 11 times if you want to get
technical some of them were half they
said be eyed ones or have courage but so
anywhere between nine and 11 times it's
like what like an average of every five
minutes or something in this movie or at
least every 10 minutes you if you can
say you can say it all you want you can
say be kind have courage but you know
what the original didn't need to say it
she just did it you know she can't we
watch behind not only and she just do it
but there was just more of an outlet for
altruism by having the mice talk you
could see the effect it had on the mice
they felt bad for her
they said they'd send a fucking song
where they're just like they keep making
her work let's make a dress where there
is this concept that by
anthropomorphizing the mice you actually
got a concept of her altruism paying off
in this one it's just kind of like yeah
she feeds the mice every once a while
once the cat looks like he's a chaser
she picks him up but it just doesn't
feel like much of a payoff and then the
fairy godmother was another good example
she's sitting there and again be kind
have courage so Helena Bonham Carter
plays the fairy godmother and she plays
Johnny Depp playing Thunder yeah and
she's dressed like an old lady and she's
a can you spare some milk and I like
that okay though I like we know but
angry but here's the thing that that's
fine if she once said that's fine but
Cinderella basically just says yeah let
me see if I can scrounge some up and
it's like literally right there in front
of her I don't know why the milk is
outside but so Judy's it puts a bullet
psyche you know it's just nothing like a
little milk but with a little kindness
she makes it so much better poof she's
the fairy godmother and then she rewards
her by doing this I'm like it that was
the medieval Facebook equivalent that
was a medieval equivalent of like
hitting like on a political meme on
Facebook like I've done my social
justice duty by clicking like on this
meme like I can get it there was no
working well you have a gray there you
have a great idea for
to actually make it without woodworking
how about that old woman keeps showing
up at the door in Cinderella because she
knows either the stepmother warns her or
literally the some of its like I see you
doing this again you're getting punished
she knows it's going to get her in
trouble and she keeps feeding this old
woman and then the old woman reveals
herself on that night that she's afraid
there there's consequences there's work
there is no impetus for Cinderella to be
courageous it was not courageous for her
to hand out a cup of milk that was just
sitting there when the stepmother and
sisters have already left that nobody's
watching it was just something like it's
just something you should do there's no
actual courage there there there's that
like I said I think there's something to
you know and maybe this does have to do
with there's an interesting conflict
maybe it's always been going on I don't
know between saying immoral and just
acting out immoral or or anything or
saying an emotion and acting out an
emotion and you know and both of those
trying to equal feel it and I think some
films like you know I I do think of this
and I do think of like you know the
Christopher Nolan's stuff and everything
whether if they just say it that doesn't
make it so you have to actually have the
character experience it and feeis and
you definitely don't she felt anything
cuz she was just too happy to you know
cheerful and stuff and then there's one
scene where she broke where she you know
broke down cried after that was
effective very quick very rushed not a
big deal really I mean in the grand
scheme of everything happens in the
movie everything else she's just so
happy I know just she might just smile I
just like smile I don't care it energy
feels kinda like you said even more
offensive that she's not a very
offensive we'd be very upset in the
original she's clearly not happy being
in that spot you know but she you know
she's just trying to make the best of it
you know like once you know the inter
means yes and she's literally a house
slave basically know if you can figure
out how to get on while being in slain
even that just very solid it's not
accepting it's just well here's one but
I have to do to stay in one piece and
also on top of it even though like I
said it's nice to have her go out it's
nice to have her talk with the prams go
to the village and stuff like that in
the other she is just always doing a
chore I mean like always in here
like one time she gets a little soot on
her face but her dress like I was my
father yeah I was I'm not correct no no
no it is like some sort of new cloth
they create like a radioactive clot that
glows neon bloomers Simpson blue yeah no
and it is away I don't know what Smurfs
they killed and what Smurfs blood they
used to dye this like it is blowing and
she always looks gorgeous yeah I mean
there's no okay planet around as I know
yeah kenneth branagh 'he's idea of
making her look world warren is to throw
a little suit on her face but this dress
never gets dirty it's amazing she sound
outside on horseback and this dress
never gets there so she's cleaning it
never gets dirty and okay I will say
this here's the irony of it I don't have
a problem with be kind have courage as
being a moral and I think there's this
mistake nowadays like I think a lot of
times characters that have feminine
traits get downplayed is like oh well
there that's not a real empowered female
because they're using kindness and you
know I don't care about that like
seriously they don't all have to be
Sarah Connor or Arya Stark or Drew
Barrymore and ever after or Ripley or
something waving a gun around or a sword
you know but you need some sort of
outlet and payoff for that moral and if
you're gonna keep saying be kind be kind
like do something with that I was
waiting for I thought it would've been
better to have the villagers try to help
Cinderella out because she was kind to
them earlier or play time on together
have no throwing it to the mice that
you're not making talking anymore it
doesn't work now in the update and the
courage there's just no courage on her
part anywhere in this movie the what the
only thing I could see is maybe like it
takes courage to forgive I me which is
you know okay yeah but then the movie
still had and see that's a case where
the movie had its cake and ate it too
because like I forgive you mother and
then it's just like even though they
were forgiven they still left the
kingdom and never returned I'm like well
and I guess that worked out didn't it
like but the thing about the no courage
is and this is what offended me the most
is I'm like okay I can look at the first
day of the movie
the fairy godmothers like okay there's
not much of an outlet whatever but there
is this scene where it's announced she's
in the village again and it's announced
hey you know she whoever was at the ball
that the prince recognizes she comes and
he'll marry her and so Cinderella
automatically is like score so she hops
on the horse rides back goes into the
Attic I'm not sure why maybe just to
change or draw other lives know the UM
slippers up there right I guess oh my
god okay yeah I guess the slippers up
there though why does she need the
slipper the prince would recognize her
instantly he saw her when she wasn't all
dolled up sister so maybe he never you
know I think it is kind of emphasized
this story is kind of a foot fetishist
you know damn come true so maybe he just
always was just like I'm sorry I have a
thing I just I I need the shoe of a face
how about the shoes yeah so she goes
back and in probably the only really
good Cate Blanchett scene and good
reveal the stepmothers already waiting
there with the slipper in hand is the
only time in the movie I felt that she
was legitimately threatening and she's
like where did you get it did you steal
it this bad and Cinderella's just like
it was given to me she makes up kind of
a quasi lie basically the old Ben Kenobi
trick well I said was true from a
certain point of view so the basically
the mother says okay alright alright
okay okay then here's what we're gonna
do you're gonna go with this slipper and
I'm gonna go with you and because no one
will believe that some peasant girl you
don't get it so I'm going to introduce
you and basically make up some sort of
lie and then you're gonna marry the
prince and then we're gonna marry off my
two idiot daughters to a couple of Lords
and then I am going to run your lives as
the head of the household now if you are
in that situation now would you do what
were the kids at your screening what
saying they would do the kids at the
screening I saw let me say so I think we
all know what we all would do because a
five year old could figure it out and
did yeah the correct answer is well you
lie and say you're going to do them and
confess everything at the palace in
front of the prince you know really
loves you and you can pretty much proved
that the stepmother is insane so but
know at this point
Cinderella says
no I will let go I I will stand up to
you and you've ruined my life but I
won't let you ruin his to protect him I
won't let you do it to which the mother
basically is like okay goodbye and locks
her in the room the amount of whispering
that went on in that screening from all
of the children in the audience to their
parents that you could just see the
thought bubbles over why did she just
fire than the parents of that uh so she
makes the critical mistake of doing that
the Queen er the not the queen of the
mother then goes and cuts some deal with
the Duke it is just like I'll tell you
what we can't let Cinderella get married
you don't want this to happen either so
let's just make sure Cinderella is never
seen again then we go on another good
scene anyway yeah that was a good it was
a great scene cuz Cate Blanchett
delivers it perfect laces are you
threatening me and she just is yes
great delivery but so okay so then he's
like I will make it look like I'm trying
so let's try this shoe on every girl in
land listen that small Kingdom but I'm
gonna say like all the women in the land
and they mentioned clearly that the
tremaine's house is the last house and
there's a whole montage this that meant
it get interrupted so this has to be
days days that this is happening so
where is Cinderella no she's obviously
whatever in the Attic starving she's
still in the Attic
and like I'm like okay maybe she hasn't
found a way out yet like me I could see
that maybe you're just stuck up there
the narrator says and I quote Cinderella
did not hear who came to the door nor
did she care because no one was there to
see her surely okay where do we start
okay again this is the again this is
because you're trying to bring logic in
this story good god yeah so we're okay
where do we start with this first I
would just assume at any age I remember
being a kid but at any age and she's
going to be 19 I'm just naturally
curious if people come up in the
driveway second it clearly demonstrates
that the window is can be open from the
inside
because my Stuart explain that in a
second so she didn't bother open a
window to see if anybody's ever coming
up third she should care fourth she
should be doing something to get the
hell out of there
five why haven't in the past few days if
she's been locked up there she at least
tries to shout to anybody within
distance that may come to the house you
know leave the window open and say hello
I'm being kept prisoner up here
six six uh she's not even worried like
she is no he's just dancing around
thinking of her prince again like she
isn't a song she is a dead girl walking
she literally the literally cate
blanchett says he's like and what do we
do about the the peasant girl whether I
do it every month with it I don't care I
mean it's implied right there just kill
her I don't give a shit and they imply
that Oh Cinderella speaks French oh she
rides a horse oh she reads all these
books so they're implying she's smart
I'm like she hasn't figured out that
she's just a dead woman being kept up
there in the Attic because her mother
just revealed she's committing fucking
treason like lying to the court of the
kingdom like so so because of this the
rats you know go and open the window and
she cuz she's just so happy thing is
it's pinging you know Holly dolly doll
whatever and they hear and it's like do
you have another maiden over there and
stuff so unless you know her standing
around and doing that there is much more
of your spammer like nothing where again
in the animated one she sees the door
closure for the right time everywhere go
down there get the key the mother is a
key go get okay it's a dog out there
with the dog go get the trap okay I
don't get it I mean like the can of
glass I can stop the rats and Cinderella
finally gets any brilliant I hate do you
like Oh Oh calling up coming on throw
the cat out the fucking window if you
have to do whatever you got to do to get
me the fuck out of this roommate in this
one the mice literally create this
little change no they're trying to go
hey look
and this is the proactive Cinderella and
that they're trying to be fair that kind
of happens when she's like in a daze
thinking she's gonna marry the prince in
the animated one but once she gets aware
that she's trapped then geez I get me
the hell out in this one yeah she's like
loading on the rats fine like I wish
they were subtitled that would have been
Greg is a very really bitch yeah what's
down here locked down here so finally
they all make a chain and open the
window and all she does is shit and
she's just singing la Li Li Li la dil de
hey nonny nonny and twirling her hair
and prancing around them there it is
like she was member betho times with a
prince and and this Abed I'm liking that
it just comes to the rats sitting there
and I'm just like the subtitle and reek
come on Lady like do some and something
else will say about that seated this is
the last really negative thing I'll say
it back because word I want to say at
least wanted to get things going but is
that again in I'm always say it took P
of so many people bitch on the anime one
yeah some of them found it but a lot of
it I'm like I think you're missing
something here that this one is not
getting because so many critics loved it
um which is that you know if you're
thinking like oh well she can't lie you
know say like oh yeah I'll do that uh
stepmother and then Judy you know know
when she said that he was given to me it
was alive from a certain sorry one light
but to in the animated one you know when
she hears that the prince is coming
gonna try the shoe on everybody she's
already working out there like you know
what are you doing dummy we gotta get
dressed and she's like she's holding
they're closing oh yeah you're right
here hold that and she's already walking
off not telling them what she knows what
she's gonna do she's like oh yeah it's
like this comes here I got the slipper I
know what I'm doing which by the way was
another big is like she finally gets let
down the anime film and she comes down
she's like oh she has passion she cares
she gets up with a super is a loss like
but nothing ever his lost there's like
this great zebra is just like BAM she's
like Lily but I have the other slipper
bitches man like and the stem I was like
oh fuck like in this one it's like the
prince shows up with the slipper and
he's like and he showed up with the
entourage and see the prince did all the
work she didn't do jack fucking
shit so yeah I guess ni what I'm really
saying with this is that as much as you
want to crap on the original which I
like it I can't act like you know some
of it is not founded I'm not Gavin no
this is an empowering strong I kind of
get it the original I Sarah fucking
Connor come yeah no but there is still
if you look at from an emotional
standpoint and you look at it from
anyone boy-girl anything lots of boys
like Cinderella you know I mean I liked
it for the rash but I mean that was it
was there a nice thing about the rats
the rats actually provided an outlet for
boys who just may want a little scary a
little bit though cuz I mean I know a
lot of our boys that feel legitimate
anywhere not cry or they but it's like
we feel legitimately bad when that dress
is ripped off its all know that's you
were emotionally invested to find me
like a child a friggin child now you
know there's gonna be one out there but
you know and when that's Ian happy if
they show on the big screen the anime
one where it's ripped apart she goes
I'll cry you will hear on taunting kids
cry you will hear nobody cry in the
audience I agree when she's crying into
this you are not emotionally invest and
the song afterward is avail I'm like you
know and there may be some boys out
there watch the whole thing through and
love the whole thing like I'm more
talking Allah okay the scene where she's
dancing with the prince no no try I fast
like even as a child didn't we fast oh
yeah always I don't ever remember seeing
their holes yeah exactly you know but
honestly I get buzz when I'm second way
there's no emotion there it's like oh
I'm in love and that that is a fault
with the movie but even fearing drying
out trying to do the chemistry and
trying to make it more realistic and
more ethical and stuff it is still just
like a three four-day romance I guess my
point is I feel like the animated film
could be tailored to boys and girls like
it was kind of a little something for
everybody this one the way it was shot
and like the focus like you talked
briefly about the dress transformation
scene remember the original and it was
Disney said it was his favorite scene in
the movie but like yeah she way she
waves the wand and the dress flows over
and it's it's a few seconds right yeah I
swear to God and this one like she
swirls around in this dress for what
feels like five minutes is it round and
around twirling
whurling ng she like gets this orgasmic
like oh oh oh and I'm like it was at
that moment that I'm just like this is
little girl porn and I don't and I don't
that's how you take it out of context
not little girl porn but porn literally
made for little girls where it's like
all the emphases on the dress and the
glitter and the sparkles right down to
the fact that she never gets dirty
the original Cinderella yeah some crappy
little like the dress Cinderella wears
the whole movie is gorgeous you know and
I'm just like I don't get that this is
made for everybody it feels like cynical
little bit like porn made for little
girls to simply sell dresses but but
under the guise that we're empowering
we're mom I'm never good when her
critics fell for it even than that okay
even then the dress seat I was telling
you about that what does she say she
finds her mother's dress this pink dress
and the stepmother and the sisters make
photo oh it's so out of fashion oh you
can left and I'm like I'm thinking about
what a terrible thing to say like it
means something to her in this and and
and yes so I'm just like okay well that
was cruel of them and that scene works
because it should be about the cruelty
so the fairy godmothers like animal will
make you a new dress and she's like
buh-buh-buh-buh-byeeeee I like this
dress this was my mother's dress you
know it has sentimental value for me
it's like I'm taking her with me if I
wear this dress I'm a very calm I was
like well can I just change it alone
she's like yeah okay and then creates a
completely different offering from the
other one how much of a pushover are you
they'll a that's literally what I looked
I was like yeah can I can I get
something that was light I mean this is
just completely different
so all right with all that said believe
it or not I actually I don't hate this
man it's just this stuff like I said I
take great insult that they're trying to
add so much logic and empowerment uh
fair enough that does not add anything
no no yeah no if you was like a lesser
version of the original you're leaving
out the character you leaving out the
emotion I still stand by that is the
most important you can still have a
working functional you know powerful
more the emphasis are on the character
and the emotion than the story in the
detail all of the cinematography all of
the great dresses all of the good music
all of the sets all of the things that
do make this film good but if you don't
have some sort of core or center to it
well like I say there's so many actors I
really want to just point out like you
know and we're talking about the
Cinderella whether she wasn't allowed to
or she's not the guy musing on down and
be like she's fine to me I think she
played the same character yeah I am
being in the sense that she's kind of
flaky but and she was much better cuz
that character had depth written too but
you need someone that's gonna bring
something to this role that doesn't have
much but you can do something with it
and you look at the King uh in this and
he brings so much to a minor role yeah
just so little and I I felt really bad
when that guy died I was just like oh no
and it was shot nice and and it took
time I wish it was in a better movie
almost because it was so gorgeous yeah
owes and I felt so bad for these
characters that's part of the problem
though most of the things that made this
film better than that would make this
one better in the original I went to the
prince
there's nothing really to help
Cinderella out the prince is a great
character yeah actually he's talking
much more about responsibility and what
to do and stuff like that but you know a
kind of fact he's gonna be a king uh and
she's technically never a princess in
this so I like that
there because when he marries her he's
King yeah so it's like it you don't get
your princess thing there but don't
tells that won't stop them from selling
that's just always so fun you know you
can't wonder who's your queen Cinderella
dress um but uh but yeah that's not as
good some of my er actors I think are
very good the the layout of course it's
a kind of erotic film gorgeously shot it
looks unbelievable um Emma's Joel
Schumacher's fan of the Opera look like
Angela's Ashes or Fight Club but this is
so like glitzy and colorful it's it's
almost retina burning but he actually
got away with it but what and they're
very they're very clever like having
pretty much the whole set be gold and
then her dress be blue is an immediate
contrast I mean so it's very clever uh
and like I said the the beginnings of
some really good ideas and stuff that
could
make this story stronger are there
there's good beginnings something like
ever after follows through
I feel like this movie is trying to be
ever after but still try to have the
stuff that makes Disney really really
marketable well this is productivity in
there as well and I don't think you can
do both because they're so going against
this is my favorite Cattleya it's the
old it's the old doctors phrase above
all do no harm and above all if you want
to do because I know some critics like
what's a traditional return to the you
know if you want a better traditional
return watch princess in the frog that
was a return to old school to say it
thought work but again that frozen
doesn't well tangled they're very well
heading gentle is well in a tangle he is
a Cinderella story it's like I'm trapped
in the tower and like I felt like there
was more of a character there to that
girl than there ever was on the relative
Rapunzel was they're going to the balls
I'd be like a what like why be way more
invested this is wonderful way so it's
like the beginnings of good ideas are
there and they start to be touched upon
but then they fall victim to I get
knowing where I can think of is the
marketing you know or that hey we can't
be two distinct we had to make it so
that you know the little girls can still
imagine cells as this character so let's
make her a little blander and let's make
these ideas not fully realize cuz we
have to have the tradition stopped you
could have that's what bothers me is
that no and they have in a lot of movie
and I would have been perfectly happy
with this film perfectly happy if it
were simply a lateral move if we went
from the old animated Cinderella
straight across to this one I'm like
okay you didn't change any much but the
core America's story is still there and
this and that you know hey if you made
it even better if you want to go like
ever after or are tangled or some update
that you feel works fine but this is
this is a regressive move this just went
in like backwards from a film made in
the 1950s it wouldn't backwards Lion
again I think they're missing the the
core focuses you have to be emotionally
invested and you can't be with this care
and you have to have it be theirs is not
interesting well and even even if she
were a little more interesting I just
don't buy the amount of passivity in her
character I found offensive like you
don't as I said you don't have to be
Arya Stark waving a sword around but you
have together got anger but yeah not
even just angry but you just have to do
the bare minimum like open a window like
that doesn't seem like too much to ask
for hair in a female character to just
care enough to be aware of your
surroundings like that's not a lot to
ask a female character I don't need some
postmodern feminist interpretation I
need somebody who can at least be like
hmm maybe I should open a door and at
least shout for help that's the thing
it's like she's not even a damsel in
distress
she's just a damsel damsel in distress
implies that they feel they're in
distress she just you think Bell has
Stockholm Syndrome some people argue
Bella's Stockholm Syndrome man this
one's just crazy she's like and I've
been locked in here for days and I'm
gonna dance wanna be like like you're
insane I I think this film over I think
it has good setups actually wonderful
setups both visually and even in the
some of the steps of the story and the
characters they're said they are not uh
push all the way through and they sat
halfway be it been yeah and I think
because of that unlike the original that
had oh definitely things wrong with it
you know I think so you can be really
big that's a big problem and fair enough
but it did follow all the way through
with you know a lot of very important
elements and that's why people that's
why kids even though there are things
you can argue are not good lessons are
still going to be watching that and not
this one because it did go all the way
and you were emotionally invested and as
I always say I mean it's like well
people know they grow up and they know
it's a fairy tale but they remember the
emotional attachment and the original
ones moral was based on kindness and
some aspect of courage but in the
original she was just really ignorant
and kept that way so all she literally
had was kindness and courage they made
this one smarter and she never uses that
intelligence for anything like anything
and I'm like okay so your moral is when
faced with impossible situations don't
use your intelligence or whatever book
smarts you may have gleaned or you know
some sort of savviness working in the
bowels of the south it's just sit there
and take it maybe by pure luck
your luck your kindness and compassion
will save you that works if you're
ignorant and have nothing but if you
have the means to do something good lord
like that's why to me it's offensive
because I could tell like I've got
nieces and nephews and I could show them
the animated film be like see you know
if you're kind to those around you in
this case it was the rats but if if you
work hard if you work hard if you're
kind then maybe your friends will help
you pay it for it doesn't always work
that way some people will betray you
some people may be jerks but you know
she helped all these mice out she you
know was kind and tried to work within
it and when trapped in a room if
somebody locks you in a room kids you
bang on the door and you scream it out
get out you try to get out ever after
you know it's like you see kids if you
work hard and you study books and you
know you try to become your own person
and you you know at least have some
sense of street smarts you may be able
to bust your way out of a situation at
the end and you know maybe you can
impress a guy by having a brain this one
I just see kids if you're locked in a
room and are being abused and threatened
to be killed um yeah just sit there but
they say be kind and have courage well
okay what does that mean I don't know I
just heard the words a lot just up there
like really it just condones abuse like
that's a weird thing because at least
the previous cinderella was like oh hell
no you ain't like but fuck this this one
just bobbidi I'll think of happier times
I did even Bell laughed
no how would you leave she laughed I
don't try to leave like it it's just
offensive like it really offends me in
the fact that so many critics fell for
this hook line and sinker just I I will
never get it this is one of those I'm
gonna disagree with the majority of
critics on to my dying day I think I
would have liked it fine if they did one
of two things and now I to the first one
is a must you have to make her
interesting I don't get truth be told
every character every person's gonna
have flaws and they're gonna be
different
not everyone you said has to be Sarah
Connor has to be Ripley you know but you
should be like have some interest in
their station in the world you should
like mirror childhood curiosities better
than what Cinderella do you should make
something distinct you should like
something best
stinked and interesting about them and
second you had to either go all
fairytale or go all logic or you have to
have a better combination like they did
in tangled frozen princess on the Frog
and so on and so forth
we're in tonight combination and this
one is just it just doesn't mesh up I I
appreciate a lot of the visuals I
appreciate what it was trying to do and
what a lot of things start off to do but
yet it didn't come from I don't think
yeah I don't like white as if I meant to
but I I'm not saying I don't think I'm
not sure with some sort of conspiracy on
the director and screenwriter spire like
we're gonna set girl characters back
like a hundred years of Dali thought
they're doing the you can see I think
they thought they were trying I think by
trying to give her token ways to appear
smarter like I think they thought they
were doing the character favor but by
not really paying attention to the rest
of the script they actually did a
disservice it's kind like when they try
to make it's like when they try to make
Lois Lane smarter it's like fair enough
but you can't have her always be a
damsel in distress thing because like
you know April O'Neill I always sort of
defend like hey what yeah she gets
captured all time that's kind of part of
her character she she's a little bit of
a doofus and always wants the story and
she's kind of greedy but that's also
kind of her charm she loves her job and
she's funny and she's distinct and you
know having a ball through it all why
was I made funnier smarter suddenly no
but when she want to work better as a
tabloid reporter is the only exit to me
as a tabloid reporter we go into
anything yeah but but but metal six news
is highly respected sir but but you know
but like in the cartoon we make Lois
Lane smarter and more intelligent than
she looks
really dumb and what she does she dumb
when she's absolutely dumb things or
gets captured doesn't get herself out
the situation is totally embezzle you
know again male or female it's just you
make em interesting you you'll forgive a
lot more it just has to be part of the
character and the questionable thing is
I swear to god there's an interview out
there with Kenneth Branagh going oh yes
no and this one she's not a damsel in
distress like and you know the other
incarnations and movies that is that I'm
like see I'm like did I see the same
movie don't ever
after dick Kennedy dick de kenneth
branagh direct a different film and
Disney secretly released another one
like or or does the mouse have a gun de
Branagh like just officer he's like yeah
that's it that's it good good stick to
the script
straight look if you want a much better
more proactive and smart and funny and
everything Cinderella movie uh go see
ever after when I think we pushed it
like a million times here if you just
like it yes bones like just really just
above and beyond this Cinderella if you
just want a bare-bones Cinderella who at
least gives somewhat of a shit than the
animated film yeah like either one works
for me it's just this one that I'm like
what this yeah I mean those and I think
you point out those are two very
opposite ends of the spectrum but those
have faults you know yet both have such
you know charm and you like the
characters and you want to see them get
through it and you are invested and if
the main character is not invested why
should we be a minimal interest in the
world around you and I think that is the
healthiest thing you can teach a child
is to at least have some sense of
curiosity like know be invest in the
world around you and pay attention just
all you need to do is just pay attention
and at least that Cinderella's ignorant
as she was kept away did that and the
one in ever after is like Steven freakin
Hawking compared to you know that one
this one just she's brain dead literally
she could have been sleeping maybe you
could have just knocked her out and made
her asleep in the last part of filming
that the prints come in like she just
twirls her hair and like dances and
again I'm not making that up she
literally does that while they're
downstairs trying on the cheese yeah hey
Melanie nany on beat world I'm gonna
pretend to dance love it like if she was
depressed maybe you know at least like
you know it's just hit her so hard I'm
not saying they get move in their favor
silicon even if there was one scene
where she was against the window like
this just how am I gonna get out of here
like this sucks even that but now she's
happy knowing better time is spirit I
wouldn't be broken and that's the thing
you can go through life without your
spirit being broken wall trying to
better yourself or let's say get the
hell out of Dodge because your evil
stepmothers going to kill
you so yeah we've really gone out of
this way so um yeah that's our thoughts
um we'll be very if you like dress porn
by all means see it it's a very pretty
movie yeah it's in the time great
cinematic stuff like that light as they
want anything even resembling if you
want to character even resembling the
competence of the first Cinderella yeah
yeah yeah I I define as bad by
definitely like the animated one more
and I like I definitely like it for
after morbid a smack Disney so it almost
no point can bury it but um but yeah so
that's how thoughts um let you know what
we think of Tim Burton's Dumbo
that's a thing now